As the founder of Playboy magazine who half?
No,
it was one of the icons of the sexual revolution in the 1960s.
Opinions about half now are very polarized,
either love and admire the man who you completely disapprove of,
the multimillion dollar empire that he created.
But no matter how you feel about Hugh Hefner,
there is no arguing that he was truly a genius when it came to business.
And,
uh,
one of the kinds publisher,
writer and is on trapping now,
Hugh Austin half note was born in Chicago in 1926.
He grew up in the middle of prohibition on his parents were conservative
Methodists.
His mother was a teacher and his father was an accountant during the Great
Depression.
His father was under a lot of pressure to work as hard as he possibly could in
order to keep his job.
He would leave the house before Hugh and his brother key if even woke up for
school and he works late into the night.
He was a very timid and shy Ellis or why he preferred to read comic books and
watch movies.
Most of the Hollywood starlets in the 1920s and thirties just happened to be
buxom blonde girls with an hourglass figure,
and so you grew up escaping into a fantasy world of romance and adventure,
wishing that he could live inside these movies.
In elementary school you did not talk very much and he didn't seem to be paying
attention to class.
He spent most of his time drawing in his notebooks with his mind ends up in the
clouds.
It was unresponsive to his just questions as well,
so they thought that he might have some sort of a learning disability.
His mother took him to a child psychologist and it turns out that he had an Iq
of 152 which makes them a genius.
The reality was that he was simply bored with what he was learning in class.
When he started going to high school,
he had his heartbroken when a girl he had a crush on started dating another boy,
and at this point he was still shy,
ended trouble communicating,
but the perceived rejection from this gal was a wake up call.
From that moment on,
he realized that he needed to reinvent himself if he ever wanted to get a
girlfriend.
He asked his friends to start calling him half instead of humans.
He began to wear nicer clothes,
Cologne and stylists hat underneath all of these outward improvements.
However,
he was still that hardcore film that he wrote plays for the theater department
and he films his own horror movies with a home video camera with his friends.
He worked on the school newspaper and drew comic books in his spare time.
When he was 15 he created his own xen,
but he had fully illustrated and he calls it shutter.
Yeah.
He wrote articles about horror movies.
He mess up with a group of friends after school calls the shutter club where
they got together to watch films and talk about them.
It was at this point that he finally came out of his shell and he was popular
enough to be elected student body president from 1944 to 1946 you have not
served in the U s army.
He used his talents in writing to work in the military.
His newspaper,
since he did not have a combat position,
be lived out the adventures in his mind by drawing comic books about fantasy
versions like one way here in a of his friends were breaking prisoners out of a
Nazi concentration camp during World War Two illustrations and photos of pinup
girls were extremely popular in order to boost soldiers' morale that were even
paintings of Miss America on the sides of airplanes,
bombers instead of staring at scantily clad strangers in his bunk,
you have now gazed at photos and letters from his fiance,
Miljard Williams.
He was very much in love with her and the plans again married when the war was
over.
After being discharged from the army,
you have no end to the University of Illinois and double majored in psychology
and creative writing.
He excelled in school and he was able to earn his bachelor's degree in just two
and a half years.
He also wrote for the College newspaper and magazine.
He was eager to marry Mildred after graduation,
but the idea that he was getting to live out the plot of a Hollywood romance
when it came crashing down before the wedding,
Mildred confessed that she had had an affair when he was away in the army.
He forgave her though and he lost his virginity on his wedding night.
They went on to have two children together,
Christine and David.
He was very much in love with Mildred and even though it broke his heart,
he believed in the old traditional way of doing things.
During an interview with the New York Times,
having to explained how he felt on his wedding day,
the magic was gone from the very beginning.
How would it have turned out without the affair was like well suited for
marriage.
I didn't know boss.
I was truly crushed
after serving in the army and graduating from college who have not got a job at
Esquire magazine,
making $60 a week with modern day inflation.
That's about $645 a week after working there for several years.
Half of the knew that he was good at his job,
so he asked his boss for a $5 a week raise.
This doesn't sound like a lot to ask,
but they still said no.
At this point he was starting to have a bit of a quarter life crisis.
I've been doing last point.
He had followed all of the rules of living the so called American dream that he
was unhappy with his job and he was in an unfaithful marriage.
He decided that he truly had nothing left to lose,
so he quit his job and worked on starting his own magazine.
You have no knew from being in the army that men love looking at pictures of
pinup girls.
When they came home from the war,
many men did not have access to it anymore because it was illegal to send
anything that was considered pornographic in the mail and that's how I men's
magazines were mostly about hunting,
fishing,
camping,
and cause have not sold.
This is a golden opportunity to start his own publication.
The only issue was that he was completely broke.
You borrowed $1,000 from his mother,
mortgaged out his furniture to the bank for $600 and convinced several investors
to help him raise a total of $8,000 to get the first issue of playboy started.
At first he thought about naming the magazine's stag party.
You just decided against it.
Since there was already a magazine called Stag,
you have no was able to by Marilyn Monroe's nude photos from accounting's as a
company who owned the rights.
These photographs were famous,
but since this was decades before people could easily share is on the Internet.
Very few people that actually seen them for just $200 he bought the rights to
the pictures and published them in the very first issue of playboy Zinn's.
Marilyn Monro was of the biggest celebrities of the time.
He couldn't have picked a better woman to place on the cover.
Magazines were flying off the shelves and they sold 50,000 copies.
The money they made from that issue was just enough to make the seconds and
after a few months they were turning a profit.
It soon enough they were selling over a million copies a month and playboy was
essentially an overnight success.
Now,
it sounds like a joke when people say they read playboy for the articles,
but there's actually a lot of truth to that statement.
Hugh Hefner was always against censorship in the media andZ ran one of the very
few publications where writers get to express themselves without holding back.
Some of the greatest authors in the world actually got their start writing for
playboy.
Ian Fleming was one of them and he went on to write James Bond's and ray
Bradbury serialized chapters of Fahrenheit four five one in the magazine before
publishing the complete novel.
Even Margaret Atwood published several short stories in playboy before writing
our feminist dystopian novel.
The Handmaid's tale in the 1950s you have not was defying all rational
convention and actually promoted feminism and women's sexual liberation as well
as racial equality.
In 1959 a series called playboys penthouse ad on the television.
For the first time,
women were shown on TV as more than just housewives who were staying home to
make a dinner and take care of the children.
The premise of the show was that the viewer followed around half an hour as he
had to classy party in his penthouse apartment.
Women Wa elegant dresses and men wore suits as they drank cocktails and had
interesting conversations while they listen to live jazz music.
It was sophisticated and that lifestyle became an aspiration for many men and
women who watched the series.
Now at this point,
you have to his marriage,
it was crumbling and he and his wife,
Mildred had agreed to allow one another to sleep with different people.
They officially called it quits in 1959 and got a divorce,
which left him free to live the bachelor lifestyle to match the playboy brand.
That same year,
he bought his first a mansion and opens the playboy club in Chicago.
Soon enough,
he would open dozens of clubs all over the country so that men could experience
the playboy and penthouse lifestyle firsthand.
By the time he turned 35 the play by empire had expanded to a lifestyle brand
worth $20 million.
As time winds on the magazine would come to be published in over 180 countries
and it became one of the top 20 brands in the entire world,
right wing conservatives.
They were against playboy from the very first issue because they considered the
magazine to be sinful trash.
He also gone a lot of criticism from the left as well because feminists saw that
it was objectifying and over sexualizing women rather than liberating them.
After receiving so much criticism who haven't published a book called the
playboy philosophy in 1962 where are you explains his ideas about sex in modern
culture and attends to explain his thought process behind you're running the
business.
In 1963 a journalist named Gloria Steinem went undercover for showing magazines
at work as a waitress and one of the playboy clubs.
She found out that these girls were being underpaid and as they were charged
fees,
whenever they committed,
even the smallest infractions,
like not smiling enough,
they were also being treated very badly by the customers.
And in the ends,
women hardly made any money in order to be sexually objectified.
Clients were given special keys that allowed them to have total access to the
playboy bunnies,
which needs the club.
A glorified brothel.
Steinem wrote about her experiences and she was seen as a hero for feminism by
exposing what was going on behind closed doors.
Now,
Hugh Hefner,
he took this criticism seriously and responded by making sure that the women
working in his clubs,
they were being treated fairly and being paid a proper wage.
But as they say,
even bad press is good press.
And despite all of the controversy,
the playboy brand continue to thrive
today,
it's difficult to imagine playboy and without the mansion filled with beautiful
girls.
But you have not did not by the iconic house in Los Angeles until 1974 the
mansion sets on five acres and comes with a movie room,
a massive wine cellar,
a gym,
tennis courts,
and even a zoo with exotic animals.
You have not began hosting at some of the biggest parties in history of the
playboy mansion with celebrity guests visiting on a regular basis.
He was still the most popular guy around even well into his old age in the year
1980 personally paid for the repair of the iconic Hollywood sign and the city of
Los Angeles gave him a star on the celebrity walk,
a thin as a thank you gift.
And the 1980s playboy began to struggle as a brand.
After it became a publicly shared cooperation,
they were competing with the likes of Penthouse magazine.
So that peak in popularity was over.
You have now handed control of the company over to his daughter,
Christie,
who became the new CEO,
have no tried to give normal domestic life another chance.
And he got married to his second wife,
Kimberly Conrad.
In 1989 she gave birth to two sons,
Maston and Cuba.
Aaron's.
They got to have a fantasy childhood growing up in the playboy mansion.
That relationship didn't last though,
and they separated in 1988 and became officially divorced in 2010 after the
separation,
you haven't to began to invite his girlfriend's to live in the house with him
and even experimented with bisexuality.
He had a polyamorous lifestyle where he had multiple girlfriends at one time,
but always had a number one girl by a site.
He knows you're admitted that he had slept with roughly 11 out of the 12 monthly
playboy cover models in 1999 one if you happen to his ex girlfriends,
Carrie Lee said that living in the playboy mansion was almost like a cult
because it was so easy to get caught up in the lifestyle and the drama with the
multiple girlfriends.
She got so caught up in the playboy lifestyle that she forgot what was
considered normal in the outside world.
However,
unlike a real cults,
the girls living in the house were free to come and go as they pleased.
They still have that own personal relationships and kept in touch with their
families.
Some of them even went to college classes full or part time and their work with
playboy helps them pay for that tuition.
In two and five the reality TV series,
girls next door premiered and it gives people a look into the lives of the
people living and working in the playboy mansion.
It reveals new Heffernan's new lifestyle with a team of employees to take care
of all of his needs.
The girls he lived with were also given an allowance to buy whatever they want
it.
Of course,
they are living in the mansion came with the understanding that Hugh Hefner only
at wanted to be involved in an open relationship where he could sleep with
whoever he wants it,
but the girls were not allowed to have another friends.
Even though this may seem like a dream scenario for some men,
the arrangement was not always a walk in the park for half an hour.
Some of the women who once lived with him sued him for palimony after that
breakup,
which is like Alan for people who are living together,
but we were not married during an interview.
One of half of his ex girlfriends,
Holly Madison,
explains that women were competing with one another for the privilege of being
in Hugh Hefner's in a circle,
dozens of small town goals which see their careers skyrocket after modeling in
playboy and they were desperate to become a part of it.
Almost every girl who was involved with the brands moved on to either having a
big modeling career or marrying a millionaire because I'm having sex with you
half know it was a very small price to pay for guaranteed fame and fortune.
As he got older,
you have no new batter than to expect any of these young women to be as true
love.
He said during an interview with the New York Times that having seven
girlfriends was actually a much easier lifestyle to manage than having just one
wife in 2012 he was 86 years old and he decided that it was finally time to
settle down.
He married Crystal Harris,
who was just 26 on the reality TV show.
Girls next door.
He was girlfriends,
showed off their happy lifestyles living in the playboy mansion,
but Holly Madison came out with a tell all book in 2015 saying that she had
actually been manipulated into staying with you half an hour for so many years.
She said that she was truly in love with him at first,
but when she finally got the exclusive relationship that she was looking for,
she was no longer in love with him.
She eventually married a millionaire event organizer or Pascal Rotella.
You have to respond to to Madison's accusations in her book saying it was an
attempt to do rewrite history for the sake of staying relevant in the media and
making money on a book deal.
And 2016 it was clear that he has in his health was declining,
so he decided to sell his mansion in Los Angeles for $100 million to a man named
Darren Metropole.
This in 2018 which are Polis,
convinced the city of Los Angeles to add protections to the house so that it can
never be torn down.
The playboy mansion has essentially been turned into a historical landmark if
you have not died peacefully in September of 2017 surrounded by his friends and
family when he was 91 years old.
Even though he never got to meet Marilyn Monroe,
he's still accredited her nudes for all of his success.
This is why he punches the burial plot right next to hers.
Love him or hate him.
You have no,
it's still an icon that will be remembered forever before he passed away.
He said this about his career.
I've never been in it for the money.
Playboy isn't a business for me.
It has been the very beginning,
a labor of love,
and that's pretty easy to say because if you don't love all of this,
you're a fool.
So I really hope you enjoyed that video.
If you did,
please do give us a thumbs up and don't forget to subscribe.
We have a few videos released every week,
so hit that subscribe button,
hit that Bell,
and you will find out about all of those.
Give us a like if you enjoyed it,
and as always,
thank you for watching.